[Music]
started as an idea what if we made a
Deadpool movie there's only a few of us
back then and looking back we had no
idea how big it would become so innocent
and yet the momentum that had started
Yetta was not really what we had in mind
nope that didn't help things it was more
of a hell no to be honest and we
eventually stopped asking we have no
idea how that happened but I promise you
you I'm looking into it well what's the
movie got greenlit I went on a massive
coke bender
so 2016 that's little hazy for me they
tell me the movie did well no 10 years
into it phase 1 has exceeded our wildest
expectations you know if you told me
back then that one movie would spawn an
expansive two movie universe I just said
that you were crazy but here we are with
actual actors a moderate special effects
budget and several low-level x-men none
of the big ones though we got to save
something for Phase two we get in close
intercept the convoy watch out for cable
edit there's this kid he's in trouble
lupard I pump the hate breaks Thanos
anyone cable get tool I can't do this
alone
back up we're gonna form a super-duper
group it's time to get back on LinkedIn
meets bettin luck
my name is chatter stark Domino I'm
lucky luck isn't a superpower it's
certainly not very cinematic yes it is
let's meet in the middle and say no it
is all right it's show time
don't call it a comeback
you're no hero you're just a clown
dressed up as a toy so talks you sure
you're not from the DC University
[Music]
bring it on one-eyed Willy
oh yeah your bullets they're really fast
and last but not least Peter
any powered want to tell us about you
know I don't have one I just saw the ad
you're in
[Music]